thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on Thursday the
9th of February I'm Cindy you the
spectators assistant editor coming up on
the show
the ghosts of Downing Street are coming
back to haunt the incumbent prime
minister
cover piece this week our political
editor Katie boss takes a look at the
Resurgence of Boris Johnson and Liz
truss and the problem they pose for
Rishi sunak she joins me along with our
chairman engineer
as labor prepares for government stalma
has taken aim at private schools
promising to make these schools pay
taxes should he win the election well
Toby Young is here to defend private
schools he joins me with former labor
advisor Fiona Miller
whilst the cultural revolution is still
within living memory for China's older
generation how much longer is it going
to be remembered for journalist Tanya
Branigan has a new book out on the
subject and joins me on the show
and finally it's Joe Biden bringing back
America First Freddie gray argues so in
this week's political column and he is
on the show too
before we get going thank you to
canonical genuity wealth management for
sponsoring this episode of the week in
60 minutes can I called our experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit can do
wealth.com for more information and if
you enjoy The Spectator then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
this week Richard Cena carried out a
reshuffle and reorganized Whitehall and
yet most of the headlines have been
dominated by his two predecessors Liz
truss and Boris Johnson who show no
signs of wanting to leave the political
stage in this week's cover article Katie
boss takes a look at what this means for
Rishi sinag she joins me now together
with the spectators chairman engineer
Katie and Andrew thank you so much for
joining me now Katie tell us about these
two ghosts of prime minister's past that
have been haunting where she seen like
this week so Richard finds himself in
quite a unique position whereby he has
two very recent predecessors in the
House of Commons both of him have plenty
left to say and I remember back when
Theresa May decided to stay on his back
bench MP when her Premiership came to an
end and lots of people said this is
great it's bucking the trend of figures
like David Cameron who headed for their
very expensive shed
um and you get all this wealth of
experience in the House of Commons the
problem is I don't think Russia Cena
will be thinking this anymore about the
fact that both Boris Johnson and Liz
trust are sticking around because you
have a situation by which uh Rishi
Scenic is trying to slow things down
they you often hear his team his
supporters say oh you know we're going
to take the Sugar Rush away you Janus
had too much fun last year the Year you
know two prime ministers going by Tori
MPS not the media
um and actually we're gonna slow things
down Michael Gove gave a speech saying
you know boring us back
um but the problem is if there is a
vacuum and politics tens of horrified
you Liz truss and Boris Johnson are on
hand to fill it so Boris Johnson and
making various interventions but
particularly on Ukraine each
intervention you see him ultimately
calling for the UK government to go
further than they are currently going
and often fell and Boris Johnson was
willing to go at the time as prime
minister and then Liz truss uh this week
and making her comeback or attempt to
come back at least and first of a 4 000
word essay in the Sunday Telegraph and
then into The Spectator on spectator TV
and in which she's made pretty clear she
plans to stick around make the case with
free markets low tax that's horrifying
plenty of her colleagues but I don't
think that's going to stop her and
Andrew
um this means that you know Liz truss
and uh Boris Johnson are not going to be
the kind of a quiet prime minister on
the back benches that Theresa May was
it's quite a crowded thing for the
Premiership I mean Katie writes are
there are three in this Premiership now
um so does Richardson need to be worried
or have both of these these former Prime
Minister's discredited in their own ways
oh I think you should be worried uh in
different ways and Katie's pieces that's
spot on unusual of a prime minister to
have two previous Prime Ministers to
worry about I mean Margaret Thatcher had
quite a lot to worry about Ted Heath so
he was never really a threat he just got
more and more curmudgeonly as he got
older
um but it's unusual though for two
primary former prime minister because in
trouble and that doing so is Katie
points out in a piece in different ways
uh Boris Johnson is a clear leadership
threat he believes he was cheated out of
leadership he sees himself as
Cincinnatus he will at some stage be
called back he believes uh sooner rather
than later he hopes uh we can talk a
little bit about how that might happen
uh
Liz truss who is not the most self-aware
of politicians but even she realizes
nobody's in any Rush ever to bring her
back that ain't gonna happen she's more
a thread on the idea side she's
championing uh low taxation small
government all the rest of it I don't
think she'll get very far after all no
one has done more to discredit economic
liberalism uh for a generation unless
trust herself so she's not exactly the
best advocate of it and we live in a era
now for good or ill of big government
big government consensus on the center
left and the center right but the ideas
will chip away because Mr sunak some
problem be pressure on him but the one
he really has to worry about is Boris
Johnson well Andrew just staying on this
trust for now you know what did you make
of her comeback I mean as Katie says on
Sunday Telegraph and on the Space Age TV
uh I didn't make very much it was a
great scoop for a spectator TV of course
uh I don't think she did anything very
original to say it was reheated stuff
that we'd heard before there's there's
no great mind uh at work there if Hayek
is her great ideological
um lodestone uh then would be good if
she learned how to pronounce it uh and I
don't it's quite hard to take because
seriously I've been given that the
cluster truss basically discredited all
the ideas that she stands for now there
is a wing of the conservative party of
course that wants lower tax of one
smaller government and all the rest of
it and I understand that and there's no
bad thing that a conservative prime
minister who is presiding over a high
tax big government regime has some
pressure on that but there are forces
that work far bigger than Liz truss uh
the pandemic the war in Ukraine the
requirement now to onshore supply lines
and everything from Pharma to gas to
energy and so on so on the need to have
an industrial strategy which everybody
seems to think we need even America's
got one now subsidizing industry so that
they come on show all of that is big
government and the choice of the next
election will not be between a version
of the list trust economics and the
labor party it will be a big government
conservative Choice versus a big
government labor Choice as well that's
the mood we're in I think we're in it
for the rest of the Decades I don't see
how that's going to change very quickly
and of course Boris Johnson is the
original big government conservative as
well so you're really if you were for
some Had A Rush of Blood to the Head
which is the jewelry party has quite
often and suddenly thinking bringing
Boris Johnson back was the answer and
you're not bringing back small
government and lower taxes you're
bringing back a former prime minister
who never saw a spending program he
didn't like even a bridge or was a
tunnel I can't remember to Ireland
yes absolutely
um well Katie this is what Liz truss's
allies in Parliament which she still has
some of are worried about isn't it I
mean this is something that she said in
that interview that these arguments are
not being made that the window for
discussion has been moved
um and yet this growth caucus is there
do they tell us about that because
they've met this week yeah so they meet
weekly
um and they're called the conservative
growth group they decided not to call
themselves the growth research group
because that tends to just a very
hostile to the Prime Minister and its
members they're about 40 insists so
they're actually you know they want to
help Rishi sunak I'm not convinced
Richardson acting so that helpful
um but when it comes to these talks uh
so I think ahead of the spring budget
they're trying to suggest there should
be you know more growth policies like we
obviously should be careful here because
it's quite hard to find a politician
maybe there's one in the green party but
he was anti-growth and instead kiss
Dharma talks about it uh Rishi next said
it's one of those five priorities what
we're talking about is how you go about
and the pace and and this group want to
affect the budget but also particularly
you know the budget before the next
election I think that's where they think
they should be you know the greatest
pressure for tax cuts Rishi sunak has
said the public aren't idiots
um they know why he can't cut tax right
now that does imply he thinks there are
people in his party who are idiots and
whether or not he meant to and but I
think in terms of how the growth group
is seen you have a situation where there
are some MPS who think it's yes they
want to influence some things now but
it's actually a caucus that in the event
of a Tory loss which currently all the
polls point to is the most likely
scenario the next election you would
have uh this caucus kind of keeping the
free market idea alive so they could
have their own candidate now if you had
a very bad loss there is a there is a
sense amongstorey MPS the party would
likely move to the right and this is
where they could be quite influential
but there is one point where you wonder
if the Boris Johnson uh group and the
Liz trust group combine and after my
piece went up I had you know one form
Minister get in touch and say is there a
number 10 they would be quite worried
about these two you know former Prime
Ministers the ghosts of prime minister's
past because while as Andrew points out
Boris Johnson is not uh you know a slim
down state Tory
um
he has a sense about him where there'll
be figures in the growth group who
associate Boris Johnson despite this
with her you know being a conservative
leader or at least person that they can
influence their policies and therefore
if you have a group that you know 2030
Die Hard Boris Johnson Loyalists and
then you have a group about 40 trust
site that means you feel rich you see it
isn't listening to them if they come
together that starts to be a group that
could cause some problems if you have
very bad local election results really
interesting especially as the trust
caucus doesn't seem to recognize how the
energy bill doesn't seem to be
ideologically in sync with what they're
saying that they believe in well and I
think in the interview that was one of
the points where a spectator editor
phrase and Nelson made the point which
is well it seems the energy package is
about 60 if you're not so many budget
and surely that is borrow and spend
rather than what you're talking about in
terms of a slim down state yeah
absolutely well Andrew what do you think
about the local elections then because
Katie writing her piece at some cynic
aides are worried about bad local
election results leading for Boris
Johnson to have some kind of Cincinnatus
like return to the to the front uh line
well let's think what's going through
Boris Johnson's mind at the at the
moment uh given that he sees himself as
Cincinnatus how soon should he try the
return now you some people may say to
him well look Tories are going to go
down come the next election uh they'll
be able to play for sunak will have to
resign a story leader if he leads him to
bad defeat uh this is your chance to get
back again be Tori leader uh and uh and
so on and begin the fight back that's
fine does anybody seriously think Boris
Johnson wants to be leader of the
opposition for five years uh which would
crib and confine his ability to earn any
money for a start he's not a natural
leader of of the opposition opposition
is not in his makeup it's a lot of hard
grind the skill stamina is finding out
Mr Johnson is not Susie to hard grind so
I don't think waiting that long is
really his option and an option that
appeals to him much more appealing is
that he believes that he could turn
things around
this side of the election that he's the
one if he gets back in having been
cheated as he sees it he can get back in
and save the day for the conservatives
my own view is that clown Cuckoo Land
but that seems to be where half the Tory
party lives these days so he'll probably
uh agree with that this does make the
mere elections I think more dangerous
than Mr sunac and those are around him
around him realize because if I'm right
and Mr Johnson hasn't got the patience
to wait for an election defeat and
thinks his role as Cincinnati is to be
back this side of the next election to
save the day for the Tories this side of
the election to propel him back as prime
minister then he has to strike before
the election and if the May results are
bad I'm not saying that triggers a
Johnson uh challenge but it will start
to lay the groundwork for the skids
being under Mr sunac and then you'll be
just entirely dependent on return to
growth to the economy to a sense that
we're not in serious decline that
nothing works in Britain you really will
have to be seen to be turning Britain
around and I think that is a big ask so
if Boris Johnson is going to strike at
all I think it will be in good time to
to be leader before the next election
and the May elections of this year will
be a crucial building block in Boris
Johnson's returns scenario and strategy
Casey I agree with Andrew in the sense
that if we get to those main local
elections I think that is the danger
point now it's not so much that perhaps
overnight you'll see borisions and try
to come back I think when you speak to
people who are starting to whisper the
idea that if the polls aren't moving at
all
um which they don't really seem to be
moving at all maybe you have to think
they're Unthinkable and would Boris
Johnson be the only thing that could
change things now there's lots of good
reason to be skeptical in the sense that
I'm sure Boris Johnson would win the
Tories some support in some areas but
vice versa probably lose the tourism
support in some areas if you look
wherever you see neck pulls well
compared to Boris Johnson and but I
think if you had very bad my local
elections it could just add to that
sense that things are not working out
and then you potentially have a build up
into the Summer where lots of people
were talking about more so I think it
could be
perhaps you know you get something
abrupt but also I think it could be that
turning point in terms of how MPS look
at Rishi Sue neck and I think one of the
problems for number 10 is there was a
sense in government despite the fact
everyone will tell you they don't expect
the polls to change overnight
he's thought there would be a slow creep
in the sense so you know exactly every
couple of weeks said chip a pole of
Labor and actually things look pretty
static and Rishi Cena's pole ratings are
coming down and more towards where the
Tory party is then where she's not
lifting up the Tory party
um which is obviously what would need to
go right for him now I still think it
was some way off Richardson act being
you know pushed out and even if there
was a Boris Johnson comeback there's a
different thing which is an attempt at a
restoration and and it being successful
and but I am struck in the past few
weeks you just are having a few more
people and you know perhaps people who
were never massive Richie Scenic fans
but they're being a little bit more
vocal now it's almost the truths of
everyone being quite well behaved after
how the Liz trust Premiership ended you
know looking into the best and thinking
we need to try and put ourselves
together I think that's wearing off at
this point well Andrew I just can't
believe we're having this conversation
at all about Boris Johnson coming back I
mean it's less than a year since he left
uh being the darling I mean should
the conservatives just resign themselves
to losing their next election instead of
just messing the country around in the
next 18 months again
but I think a lot of them are residing
themselves to losing the next election
and you're right it is a bizarre uh
conversation uh to have given the manner
in which Mr Johnson left Downing Street
entirely of his own making not even over
policy entirely over it was death by a
thousand cats and the cuts were made
worse because he tried to deny the where
any uh Cuts in the sense of any parties
in Downing Street that he knew of all
nonsense that undermined them in the end
and he made it much much worse but the
reality is that uh this there has been
as Casey's saying that no sunak bouncing
the poll that it's clear Mr sunak for
all his many attributes and serious
purpose and hard work and brains there
is no X Factor there no X Factor that's
leading to any
measurable change in the polls and the
mountain to climb in terms of getting
the country back on track again and you
add all that up and the fact that Mr
Johnson is wedding in the wings and
believes that he can come back then that
does make Mr Johnson more dangerous it
does seem to me however
um
to use a technical term Bonkers to think
that this would uh
result in the Tories coming back because
it would be an incredible leap into the
unknown again I mean Boris Johnson is a
form of political long covet that uh
people that he's touched in his time as
prime minister and before it comes back
to haunt them you don't think that as
the chairman of the BBC ask these Tony
donors ask the women Who provided the
gold wallpaper or whatever it was for 10
Downing Street uh you know the the just
see what happens when this parliamentary
inquiry gets underway as to whether he
lied to Parliament or not about the uh
parties which don't go through all that
uh yeah and that'll all be public that
will all be on the television Airwaves
so it seems to me it's a huge risk you
don't know what's going to come out of
the woodwork with Boris Johnson and when
it does command is usually not something
very pleasant so that's why I just think
it's a it would be a crazy risk but I
don't rule out the Tory party in this
current state taking that risk
and I think the very fact of having this
discussion points to what um I think is
the most likely problem for Richard C
Nick which is one who's actually really
experiencing right now which is yes
there is a chance of Boris Johnson come
back before the next election but for
the reasons Andrew just talked us
through so the Privileges committee we
also have the resignation honors list by
Boris Johnson ever that comes out which
is going to be a massive political
headache and it's going to become Richie
sunax problem it's going to become the
Tory party's problem so all these things
um Boris Johnson's interventions are
very issues there's worries that Boris
Johnson could talk about the Northern
Ireland protocols there's a deal in the
coming weeks it means that even without
a comeback Boris Johnson is proving a
problem for Rishi sunak and is just
adding to the sensor it's hard for Rishi
Cena to turn the page or even make his
own impression with the public when you
have such big characters still lurking
around
um who are not shy about coming forward
well Katie and Andrew thank you very
much for joining sweet taste TV
speaking of the next election kier's
thumb is starting to put forward Labor's
policy platform including a proposal to
start levying v80 on private schools but
Toby Young writes in this week's
magazine that this wouldn't raise any
money and doesn't even tackle that big
of an unfairness he joins me now
together with Fiona Miller a campaigner
for comprehensive schools and a former
education advisor to Tony Blair
so Toby for the magazine this week you
write that Labor's policy to add taxes
onto private schools would lose the
treasury money harm social mobility and
won't make the education system fairer
can we start with the first part of that
I mean how would a treasury actually
lose money by levying this tax
yeah well um labor estimates that this
will raise about 1.7 billion and it's
announced I think various things that
intend to spend this bounty on but
according to an analysis by a financial
consultancy company called Baines Cutler
which provides consultancy services to
Independent Schools it would actually
lose the treasury money and the way they
work this out is first of all I mean I
think that where um uh Kia stalma has
got the 1.6 billion from at 1.7 billion
it's first of all 1.6 would just be
multiplying what parents are currently
paying by way of private school fees by
20 and then you add the additional
amount that private schools will be
paying when they're forced to pay full
business rates
um but the problem is that when you make
schools when you make school fees liable
for vat schools can then claim back some
of their some of the vat they're playing
on supplies which means they can
probably lower their fees a little bit
and according to base Cutler actually
the Bounty will be more like 15 of what
parents are paying now rather than 20
and in addition and this is the really
critical Factor because that will
nevertheless make private school fees
unaffordable for vast suede's appearance
people imagine that if you're sending
your child to a private school you're
very wealthy you're a member of the
super rich not true often middle class
families making sacrifices
um one one partner giving up all their
salary to pay children school fees so if
they do go up I mean it's price
sensitive if they do go up Ben's Cutler
estimates that about a quarter of
private school students will move into
the state sector so that's reducing the
take by another 25 but critically if
they have to move into the state sector
the state then has to pay to educate
them in the state sector and not only
does that mean paying for more teachers
it also means building new classrooms
and Bank Cutler estimate that the total
cost to the treasury will be about 416
million a year over the five-year period
of the next Labor government well Fiona
do you agree with those calculations
well I mean the first point to make is
that there's the government's own
figures say that the school role is
going to drop by a million pounds over
the a million pupils over the next
decade so that there is a lot of spare
capacity in the system and give you one
example I mean there are 80 000 School
places in London at the moment that
aren't filled the 90 000 pupils in the
private sector so they could easily be
accommodated without any extra cost and
I mean this 25 it seems It's a sort of
rough estimate nobody knows how many
parents would come back into the state
sector but for me it it isn't even a
matter really of the money it's a matter
of principle there are eight million
children in state schools including our
own Toby who are funded at about five
thousand pounds per pupil per year there
are half a million children in private
schools funded approximately fifteen
thousand pounds a year and that's
fundamentally unfair you cannot have a
system where a small minority of
children are funded to such an extent
that's therefore that's then subsidized
by the taxpayer in this way so I think
it's a political argument we don't
believe in subsidizing the education of
the most well-off in society we believe
in redistributing the money however much
it is to the least well-off who bloody
well needed at the moment I I think
you've got it um back to front Fiona
it's not that the taxpayer are
subsidizing uh taxpayers are subsidizing
private school parents uh it's the other
way around private school parents are
paying twice over for Education once for
their own children's education and the
second time for other people's
children's education
um uh and you know it it seems to be
looking a gift horse in the mouth to say
to these parents who are paying twice
over for education and paying for other
people's children as well as their own
sorry you're going to have to pay more
for your own children's education I mean
aren't they paying enough given that
they're paying twice you don't you don't
say to people please leave the National
Health Service and go privately to save
the state money we want public services
that are used by everybody across the
community that's what gives them their
status and their validity in society if
they've become just a rump service for
poorer people they're done for so I
think we want we want public services to
be used by everyone and I would welcome
back all those parents into the state
sector and I'm sure they'll find it's
much better than they think it is and
they would enrich all their local state
schools as you've always known I make
that case well we can go back and forth
about whether it would actually
um cost the taxpayer money or the
taxpayer would gain but let's let's just
take it for granted that it's called can
I ask you a question do you accept that
it is fair that a small group of pupils
in this country are funded to such a a a
lavish extent compared to the majority
of children understand do you think
that's fair one of the the points I make
in my article Fiona is that about five
years ago I was the co-author along with
several people of a paper that was
published in a peer-reviewed scientific
journal in which we looked at the GCSE
performance of a group of private school
pupils and a group of pupils at State
schools controlling for all the
characteristics they arrived at the
schools with so prior attainment
parental socioeconomic status the
genetic markers associated with with
educational achievement and we found
that if you control for all those
factors the GCSE results of children in
private schools are really no different
to the GCSE results of children in state
schools Toby does the inequality come a
bit later down the line then when it
comes to universities because private
school children are disproportionately
more likely to get into Oxbridge for
example yeah but you can't just look at
that Cindy you have to look at whether
if you control for all the all the
characteristics they bring with them
when they arrive at the school they're
still doing better and children with
those same characteristics at State
schools are just as likely to get into
universities you can't just look at the
percentage of people in private schools
are getting to universities you have to
look at whether they're actually getting
a leg up in virtue of going to private
schools and the evidence suggests
they're not
well in terms of exam grades no but of
course people there's a lot more to
private education than just the exam
results and anyway you're talking about
one sliver of State School educated
people so ones I'm talking about are the
poorest ones who'd never be in the
private sector in the first place you're
paying for the sports facilities you're
paying for the contacts you're paying
for the the tutors and the sixth form
will help you get into Oxford and
Cambridge you're paying for the drama
you're paying for the enrichment you're
paying for the school trips and things
that you know that is just not
affordable in the state sector at the
moment that's fundamentally unfair you
could say it's unfair that some people
live in bigger houses
um but I think let's look you say Fiona
that you're concerned about the least
well-off children and how they're doing
in state schools I say in my article and
I think this is an argument you'd
understand that if you force lots of
aspirational middle class parents to
educate their children in the state
sector because you make private school
fees unaffordable they're going to find
places in the highest performing State
schools and that's going to push out but
we know this you know
of course children are not in the
highest performing States when a school
is doing well a state school a good
comprehensive middle class parents will
move Heaven and Earth they'll game the
system to get their children in whether
it means going to church and pretending
to be past Christians buying property in
the catchment area of the school
whatever it takes they'll do it to get
their child into the high performing
school and the children that will suffer
as a result of all that migration from
the private to the state sector are the
disadvantaged children that currently
Canada they're not in those schools Toby
they're not in those schools you know
that perfectly well they're not in those
schools they're not in the grammar
Schools they're not in the selective
Church Schools they're in the schools
that you know don't fiddle their
admissions in that way incidentally you
know perfectly well that I've always
been in favor of admissions reform so I
would make that a big labor policy
alongside this one so that you did make
access to the best best schools more
accessible to the poorest children I'm
just interested in how we get invest
more money in the education of the
poorest children in society at a time
when the Gap is widening not narrowing
between the richest and the poorest and
I think it's frankly obscene that the
funding differentials between the state
and the private schools are so extreme
that anything we can do to narrow that
is a good thing and I think that's what
this proposal is attempting to do but
Fiona if the sums don't add up in the
way that Toby has set out what is the
point I don't accept they don't add up
because I think there's plenty of
capacity in the state system and I've
told you the government's own figures
say they're going to be a million extra
places in the next decade there's plenty
of capacity in the state system as it is
funded at the moment to absorb extra
children in fact the state system would
would very much love to have those extra
children because otherwise State schools
are going to have to close Fiona the the
schools which have spare capacity are
the least successful schools the schools
that parents don't want to send their
children to and the middle class
children the refugees from the private
sector you know as well as me are not
going to end up in those schools it's
the children they push out of the better
schools that are going to be shunted
into those low performing models I can
give you many examples of State schools
that have been turned around by the
arrival of a group of motivated middle
class parents and I'm sure you know many
of them yourself so I don't ex all I'm
not what I'm saying is that the money is
there to fund a million pupils at the
moment who won't be there in 10 years
time so that it's not going to cost the
state any more money if 20 even if 150
000 children come in from the state
sector and also as you perfectly well
know these State these private school
places are distributed very unequally
across the country they tend to be in
certain cities and there are huge sways
that countries don't have many children
in private education so in places like
London where there are a lot of extra
School places at the moment it would be
perfectly easy to to accommodate them
even in what a perfectly good schools at
the moment can we
a bit more about something that both of
you have missed how middle class Parents
game the system you know if you know you
mentioned admissions reform how would
that look like when it comes to the
state sector because you know I went to
a grammar school and I saw lots of
middle class parents who probably could
have afforded private education but
because my grammar school was so good
they put them into the catchment area
and to put them through the 11 plus for
that school and and as you say pushed
out people who otherwise uh would have
got there but the 11 plus is the biggest
middle class you know Swindle to get
into school because you can pay for
coaching for your children from the age
of seven or eight to pass the test and
that's why grammar schools have very
very few children eligible for free
School meals or the pupil premiums so
that needs to go for a start I think the
way the church schools and many Church
schools admit their pupils need to be
looked at and I think that the proximity
uh criteria need to be look at because
that means people can buy houses in
those areas I would certainly reform all
that as well you know I mean bigger
priority for me in a way but we're not
talking about that at the moment we're
talking about charity successive labor
governments have failed to enact those
admissions
happen it's politically too difficult
it's too unpopular grammar schools are
located in marginal constituencies
losing this policy as a kind of Elixir
which will cure unfairness in the system
but you know that without admissions
reform it'll just have a negative impact
on social Mobility not a positive one
and can I make another point in
connection with social Mobility Cindy
which is that at the moment in order to
retain their charitable status
Independent Schools do an enormous
amount of work to try and help uh less
less Advantage children get us get a
step up so about 85 percent of
Independent Schools have partnership
arrangements with local state schools
the school that I helped set up in West
London uh the West London free school
has an arrangement with Latimer a next
door private school they let us use some
of their facilities yeah chromas from
the rich man's table exactly pupils
there are 40 000 pupils in the
independent school sector that benefit
from scholarships and bursaries Kia
starmer himself was the beneficiary of a
bursary when he went to reigate grammar
school all those children currently
getting a leg up being given a helping
hand by the independent sector it won't
stop altogether but they won't have the
same incentive to engage in that
partnership work to create those
personalities if there's no tax benefit
to retaining
one percent of children in the private
sector on full bursaries right unless
you're on a full bursary it's going to
be quite expensive for you some of those
bursaries are offered to families who
earn a hundred thousand pounds a year
plus
and they're mostly linked to
academically selective tests so they're
not you're not going to be you know
perfectly well you're not going to be
taking the most disadvantaged primary
school pupils you're going to be taking
in the pupils who who coached or who've
kept up through Primary School to pass
the selective test and the question I
always ask private school heads is how
many children in your schools do you
have who are eligible for the pupil
premium or how many are there across the
independent sector answer comes they're
none because they don't count them
because there aren't any and frankly if
these schools were doing so much to
address disadvantage they should be able
to answer that question
don't you think uh I'm sure well you
know I think the figures I've been the
figures I've I've got are that 40 000
children benefit from bursaries and
scholarships but they're families you
earn up they can earn upwards of forty
fifty sixty thousand pounds nonetheless
they're making school fees affordable
for those who currently can't afford it
because they're not particularly well
off it's a myth to think that only the
super rich can afford private education
but why is making school fees affordable
for a tiny proportion of people why
would that be our priority when we're
talking about leveling up what we should
be worried about what's happening to
those millions of children who have who
are not funded well enough to get the
chances in life that they need and if
this policy can even throw half a
million pounds back into the state
sector frankly it's a good thing in my
view can I suggest can I suggest a
middle ground here instead of scrapping
charitable status altogether
um can we say that the threshold you
have to meet to to Get Charitable status
the stuff you have to contribute back to
the community back to your local state
schools has to be much much higher you
know Toby I hear you what you're saying
about these statistics but I think we
all know private schools that do the
bare minimum in order to kind of meet
some kind of charitable responsibility
you know private schools who let the
local state school use their swimming
pool for two hours a week or something
like that you know that's just not
enough you know even if you count the
bursaries why don't we say raise the
threshold if you can meet the threshold
where you're really helping local state
schools then you can keep that
charitable status and if you can't then
you don't do you think that would work
Toby I I've got no objection to making
the
um burdens on governors of Independent
Schools even higher to retain their tax
benefits but I just can't see
um how you can believe that charging VAT
on school fees and charging full
business rates on school buildings is
actually going to bring in money given
that the number of children that will
have to move out of that sector and be
educated in the state sector as a
consequence even if there are empty
places you're still going to have to
employ more teachers
otherwise would if those children would
continue to be educated in the private
sector no those teachers are coming
currently being employed by the state
sector because as pupils go you won't
need as many of them so the budget is
there now but the point is I think that
is a very good idea and so what about
this for an idea why do we say to the
Independent Schools if you want to keep
your charitable status you take in the
pupils who are hardest to teach most
likely to be excluded can't pass your
academic selective tests you know live
at the council flat that most of those
parents are trying to get children away
from why do you take them in and let's
see what they say I can tell you what
they'll say they won't want it because
that's not what their parents are paying
for it's an interesting point Fiona
which is that many pupil referral units
many special schools schools for
children with special educational needs
are Independent Schools they charge fees
usually those fees are paid by the local
Authority not in every case when labor
says it's going to charge VAT on
independent school fees and charge full
business rates for school buildings in
the private sector does it mean those
schools as well and if not how's it
going to differentiate between some
private schools but not all private
schools I think we're gonna have to
leave it there because we are running
out of time but Fiona and Toby thanks
very much and I hope that KIA Sam or
someone in labor is is watching because
maybe we've come out with a middle
ground
if you enjoy spectator TV why not
subscribe to the magazine as well you
can get 12 weeks off The Spectator in
print and online for just 12 pounds on
top of that we'll give you a 20 pound
Amazon gift voucher for free go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
now you might think that the cultural
revolution is completely censored in
China but a new book sheds light on the
ways in which those 10 years of Madness
are still commemorated today red memory
is by journalist Tanya Branigan and is
reviewed in the magazine this week she
joins me now
so Tanya welcome to spectator TV now the
term cultural revolution has been banded
around a lot in the last few years as
the West talks about the culture wars
and we talk about campus freedom of
speech and all this sort of stuff but
anyone reading your book will be able to
see that actually the real Cultural
Revolution was much more serious than
anything that we've seen here so can you
tell us keep in mind viewers of the the
violence of the real one that happened
in China in 1966.
yes I mean it was absolutely devastating
there were tens of millions of people
who are hounded around 2 million people
died uh sometimes beaten to death
sometimes executed sometimes killing
themselves because they were under such
huge pressure so the human toll was
absolutely immense but of course the
other thing that was really distinctive
about it was that it was really driven
from the top it was Mao's attempt to
reassert his Supremacy and that's one of
the many reasons why I think it's so
misleading to sort of try and draw
comparisons between that and what we see
today and when we'd say people were
hounded they were hounded for what's
been seen as not revolutionary enough
yes I mean for Thought crimes
essentially for being seen as not
revolutionary enough
um in many cases similarly for their
simply for their family background I
mean even infants in the worst cases
were killed because they were seen as
belonging to landlord families
um so people could for all sorts of
reasons uh fall foul either in the early
stages of the red guards these sort of
political Vigilantes but then in the
later stages when it became sort of more
bureaucratic really in the Revolutionary
committees had taken over again people
were being tortured and killed for their
sort of supposed part in conspiracies
which really never existed or only
existed in sort of absolutely tiny form
and that these campaigns would sort of
spiral out of control and suck so many
people in and it only really ended with
the death of Mal but that happened in
1976 so I think it was so extensive
across the country and so recent in In
Living memory really of of all Chinese
families and my family we have our own
stories is my my mom and her siblings
still remember being taken in by
relatives when her own parents were
being denounced
um so it's no wonder that the country
still remembers at least within families
but your book is also about the public
memory of the cultural revolution can
you tell us about that because it seems
like such a politically sensitive period
that surely the Chinese Communist party
is embarrassed by it but yet there are
still places and moments where you can
have public memory of that time
so it's quite a complex one I think it's
not completely Taboo in the way that for
example the Crackdown in 1989 on
um the pro-democracy protesters was but
it's certainly always been sensitive and
it's become much more so over the years
um it's become much more tightly policed
in discussions there's very little
discussion of it officially only
occasionally as it sort of raised as
this kind of bogeyman this idea of sort
of the turmoil that China could slip
back into if the authorities don't keep
tight control on things in general it's
been much more about sort of controlling
that space and preventing people from
talking about it and alongside that of
course has gone the personal trauma
which is often prevented so many people
from speaking about it
but there are people who have come
forward I mean that was really the what
United the people in red memory the fact
that they wore people who'd chosen to
remember in some way and there are
certain elements of it or particularly
there's one element of it that the
um party is willing to remember and even
to celebrate which is this period in
which 17 million young people I mean as
young as sort of 14 in many cases were
sent off down to labor in the
countryside thinking they were going to
be there forever and it was devastating
for them I mean these were incredibly
poor areas they were struggling to make
a living a significant number of them
never came back they were sort of killed
in work accidents or they died of
malaria
um and yet this is the one part that the
party will remember because of course Xi
Jinping was among the people who was
sent down he spent around seven years
toiling in the countryside and so
essentially uh the party says well look
he has seen what it's like to live in
these grueling conditions he knows how
how tough it is for ordinary Chinese
people he can enjoy the worst he can
take this on and really he's he's one of
you
imagine of how this has impact
presidency is such a fascinating one
there's one I've looked at on my podcast
Chinese Whispers but you would think
that a trauma like this directed from
very much from the Chinese Communist
party where his own father was was a
senior official and then purged uh
although before the coach Revolution you
would think that something like this
would traumatize a young man to the
extent to to make him a Critic of the
CCP rather than the the leader of it now
so how do you think it has impacted him
it's so fascinating isn't it because
people have reacted to this time in such
different ways and there's no better
example of that really than Xi Jinping
himself so obviously his father was a
revered figure who suffered greatly uh
in the time uh his elder sister in fact
we believe his half-sister killed
herself because of the political
pressure the family was under so there's
no doubt it was incredibly painful for
him and yet while his father and other
party Elders when they were
rehabilitated afterwards did their
utmost to ensure that there were sort of
safeguards that there could never be a
strong man leader of Mao's kind again
and set up all these sort of norms for
Collective rulership rules such as
um agreements on term limits and things
like this she has really torn all of
that up and of course he's now China's
indefinite leader he's done two terms
and he's carrying on we don't know how
long he's going to be there he's
dismantled a lot of the safeguards that
were were there and it seems quite
perverse in a sense but I suppose you
could argue that really the lesson he
took
um was that politics is very
unpredictable and if you are anywhere
near the top you want to be in charge
and you want to have a really tight grip
on what's going on and I think
particularly
um for him that idea which is runs quite
deep I think among people you can't have
any sort of
space there for Dissent that when people
start to dissent that is dangerous you
don't want the masses to be involved in
any way and so while he's been very good
much better than sort of the last couple
of leaders it's shaping a message that
speaks to Ordinary People this kind of
emotional narrative for China that
speaks to the masses uh he's also
clearly imposed very sort of tough
political constraints of a type that we
really hadn't seen for a long while yes
absolutely but but the party's reaction
to the cultural revolution hasn't always
been as highly controlled as it is it
seems these days because immediately
afterwards you know in 1981 you had this
resolution where the party itself tried
to make sense of it so can you tell us
about what the party's own narrative
about the cultural revolution was at
that time and is that why there are
these moments that gaps in which you
find cultural revolution museums
cultural revolution galleries even the
cultural revolution themed restaurants
is that why it manages to not be as
taboo as the Tiananmen Square protest in
1989.
so there's no doubt that in some ways
actually memories of the cultural
revolution are quite useful in the
aftermath of Mao's death in helping the
country's new leaders to sort of move
the country forward and particularly
under Dome Xiaoping when he wanted to
take this turn towards the market it
really Justified the move away from
Orthodox marism the fact you had this
sort of outpouring of what was called
scar literature the Memoirs and the
novels sort of talking about how
terrible it had all been and it really
reminded people of the need to move away
from the years of maoism and towards
this very new vision of China that was
obviously
while enticing for some obviously must
have seemed quite threatening uh brought
insecurity with it for many those
um kinds of memories I suppose uh did
what the party wanted them to and then
they wanted to move on from there they
certainly didn't want people to dwell on
it so in fact even when the official
verdict was being drafted uh one of the
things that dung said to the people
working on it was that the point of this
was really to help People Unite and look
forward it wasn't the kind of
remembering that countries sometimes do
when they say never again we're going to
you know focus on this and make sure
nobody forgets it was about saying we're
going to deal with this subject we're
going to decide we're going a new way
and then we're going to move on don't
keep looking backwards
um and so official references to the
cultural revolution now are so sort of
glancing the official verdict stands
that this was a catastrophe that Mao was
really LED astray by the gang of four
and Lindbergh but
um it's not something that the party
wants people to think about
and so while it did create a certain
amount of space for Scholars of the
cultural revolution for people who
wanted as you say to set up cultural
revolution uh museums and so forth it
was a very limited space
um and they've always had to battle uh
the museum is a classic example of
something that has survived by being
below the radar so once it started
getting a lot of visitors they started
sort of taking the signposts down and
they stopped the Press reporting on it
it was allowed to survive but it wasn't
allowed to thrive and the other thing I
think that's really important to
remember is that so much of what goes on
in China obviously is about people
taking the initiative finding spaces
creating spaces and there was a point
where Civil Society
um and Scholars and historians had
clawed out a certain amount of space to
talk about difficult aspects of China's
history through their sort of dedication
and their courage and that's really
something that has been reigned in the
party has reasserted a kind of political
Orthodoxy so many of these initiatives
just wouldn't be possible now we've even
seen you know magazines such as annals
of the yellow Emperor which was this
very bold magazine sort of mostly made
up of sort of octogenarians looking
usually from within the system looking
back at the country's history you know
that's really been sort of taken over
that whole
sphere I think has really been
severely restricted almost shut down
what Tanya what does this mean for
future generations of China then because
as I say it's within living memory but
certainly not within my living memory uh
when people when future Generations come
in China and if it's not publicly
um known in the in the ways that you're
talking about being tightened up what
does that mean for how much the Chinese
know about what happened in those 10
years in the future
well I think one thing that's so
striking is that even when they know a
little bit they don't really understand
it
um and so we saw this case for example
where students
um were very heavily criticized on
social media because they'd taken these
graduation photos where they sort of
mocked up struggle scenes as if they
were posing in these sort of
denunciation sessions from the cultural
revolution which of course many
survivors found highly offensive but we
were also talking about a generation
that had never really been allowed to
learn in full about what the cultural
revolution actually meant so it seemed
to me entirely unsurprising that they
wouldn't grasp actually what they were
mimicking
um
so I think there is a real issue many
people as I said older people simply
aren't willing to talk about it at all
so a very common thing is that people
either know that something has happened
in their families but nobody's willing
to talk about it
um in some cases they don't know at all
so one of the psychotherapists I spoke
to who was working uh with victims of
the cultural revolution actually said it
was only when she started doing the work
that she realized something had happened
within her own family and what's so
striking about the work of the
psychotherapists like her is that
they've found the effects of the
cultural revolution carrying on not only
into children but even into
grandchildren the traumas uh reproduced
often perhaps especially where families
haven't been able to speak about them
but the way it's shaped and scarred
those people that those effects are
still being felt and will continue to be
felt I think until perhaps China is
ready to address this well Tanya you so
much for joining spectator TV and I'm
sure your book will be adding to the
memory of that period
um thanks again
and finally Biden delivered his State of
the Union Address this week an annual
event famous for its Pomp and pageantry
the takeaway seems to be that Biden is
as much into America First As Trump was
writes Freddie gray in this week's
political column he also hosts our
Americano podcast Freddie joins me now
so Freddie welcome to spectator TV hello
hello um tell us about boyden's main
messages in his State of the Union
speech this week well uh first of all
let's say it was actually a good speech
I think it was the best speech I've
heard Biden give since he's being
president okay uh he didn't sound frail
he didn't stumble too much there was a
couple of weird slips and a couple of
strange moments
um like when he was talking about China
he he said he suddenly got very angry
for no obvious reason right and said no
leader in the world name me one leader
in the world who would swap places with
Z right now I you can't name one oh okay
that's very old I could think of a few
actually but um but anyway apart from
that it was it was a it was it wasn't a
very foreign policy base yeah uh last
year he started on Ukraine because
obviously that was the big story at the
time and it very much dominated his his
State of the Union Address his first
State of the Union Address uh this year
it was very much I've called it in this
week it was sort of abide in America
first speech and actually you
understand listen to it you understood
the ways in which he's adapted
Trump's
economically populist message yeah in a
sort of politically correct way so
there's a little by American stuff which
he said before uh there was a lot of
sort of you know Corporate America needs
to pay up uh messaging so it's kind of
reach out to the left of his party
economically
um but really it was a it was a pitch to
America it was also saying because he
was speaking for the first time to a
republican majority in the house it was
saying I'm going to work with you while
brilliantly sort of undermining him it
was very clever the way he said uh for
instance he was talking about bringing
down the cost of drug prices for
everyday Americans and he turned to the
house who were heckling him to the
Republican side of the house and said
don't worry big Farmer's still going to
get their money you know and that that's
that's good Politics as it makes
Republicans look like sort of lobbied
chills for for big Pharma yeah I mean
this is the kind of stuff that he's
quite good at isn't he just trying to be
cross-partisan also appealing to a bit
more Blue Collar voters and policies and
stuff like that so yeah in some respect
it's probably the best of what he should
be yeah I think it's his comfort zone
yeah I mean having spent five decades in
Washington and particularly in as a time
in his time as vice president under
Obama I think he understood that in
those years 2010 to 2012 was where Obama
sort of turned his presidency around
because he had a republican majority in
the house so he was constantly able to
pitch himself to the American people as
saying there's all this stuff we'd like
to do but we're scuppered by these docs
Republicans uh who are mean and they're
Shilling for big business and so on
that's what Biden wants to do now and
it's pretty effective politics well tell
me more about this kind of mating
America thing that he's trying to make
happen now you mentioned the chips act
in your yeah in your piece well the
chips Act was one of the first things he
brought up uh which is obviously giving
280 billion I think it is towards
America's semiconductor industry and
actually trying to freeze out China's
semiconductor industry there's also
infrastructure which he passed a big
infrastructure bill there's more to come
and that is going to be exclusively by
American so federally federally mandated
projects will only buy American projects
say that's Timber copper Etc et cetera
and other presidents have committed to
that as he said but they've always found
ways around it he's insisting that he's
not going to do that and that is kind of
good populist catnip Americans like to
hear that yeah absolutely and is that
why Trump praised him because as you're
writing a piece even Trump has said you
know he's a is not natural for him but
you've got to give him credit for trying
yes well it was a bit backhanded that
was a little bit backhanded because he
was doing what Biden was doing we're
pretending to be nice but actually
stabbing him in the back right because
he posted it with a video about the
border which of course is Biden's big
weak point for a lot of Voters he hasn't
really made any steps towards securing
the border and as a major immigration
illegal immigration crisis there but yes
Biden did I mean sorry Trump did sound
um actually quite magnanimous you know
give him credit for trying as far as
Trump goes that's pretty that's pretty
generous but he did say that on Truth
social I mean this is a bit of a
digression but is he coming back to
Twitter at any point I mean he now can
but he's just he used to be holding he
hasn't done it yet uh the speculations
that he might as his campaign
intensifies and that he's planning a big
Facebook comeback but that's just been
reported there's no sign of it yet yeah
okay well just going back to Biden then
I mean you mentioned that foreign policy
wasn't a heavy feature in this speech is
that a surprise given how much uh you
know the Chinese spy balloon has been
obsessing the American News agenda over
the last week yes well his team briefed
out beforehand that he would not be
mentioning the balloon oh okay yeah they
said the word balloon will not come up
and indeed it didn't come up although he
did say as we showed this week when
American sovereignty is threatened right
uh we will act and we did but I think a
lot of Americans find that story all
very odd
um it seemed to be only after the media
sort of picked up on this story became a
kind of outcry
that Biden finally shot the American
government finally shot down this
balloon so he sort of skimmed over that
really overall do you think he should
have done and maybe he should have made
it a point of saying you know we react
when the events when events develop you
know blink is no longer going to China
at least in the short term you know look
at us being tough on China do you think
you should have made more of a point of
saying that maybe maybe although I think
he's he's sticking quite closely to the
Biden Doctrine on China which is
cooperation where you can uh standing up
where you where you should
um and it's not an idiotic policy uh but
it's obviously quite hard to do at a
time when you're simultaneously trying
to say autocracies on the rise democracy
has to defeat it uh and yet we're going
to keep cooperating with China yeah
absolutely and speaking of that zelenski
is in London this week asking for more
fighter jets but what I the feeling I
get from Rishi Cena is that he won't do
anything that the Americans won't do so
do you think the Americans could be
giving more to Ukraine to fight this
other autocracy in the world well it
interesting is because Biden is is
nervous about being the the obvious
leader of the of the Ukrainian effort
even though it's very very obvious to
everybody that it's America that drives
this train
um so I think what you'll probably have
again is is the what you had with the
tanks which is if if we if the West
supplies all subjects to Ukraine uh you
will have other countries going first
getting ahead of them Britain or is
leading the way uh and then
um Biden's sort of coming in behind but
with the actual stuff that matters the
volume of weaponry and money that
matters right absolutely
um and Freddie just before we finish up
you know can you give British viewers an
idea of how important the state of the
union is and what kind of occasion is it
meant to be because you mentioned that
Bonnie was there yeah and I had to look
online and he was sitting next to you
Nancy Pelosi's husband is that the kind
of thing that happens that celebrities
just drop in and out and people are
heckling like what what kind of vibe is
come it's become this very weird uh
American ritual right
um and it's a sort of weird Carnival of
um Imperial power basically and it was
never meant to be this as a lot of
people have said this week uh you know
in the U.S Constitution there was this
line that the President should report
from time to time right to Congress and
so it could be an email it could be a it
could be a letter or even a text message
or even a truth truth social post uh but
but in fact it's turned into this
extraordinary set piece where the the
president sort of comes in there's a lot
of starting to Applause a lot of kind of
fake poly tests but now there's also the
heckling that's come in recently more it
happened a lot with Trump Nancy Pelosi
or another ripped up the speech behind
him this yesterday uh the Republicans
were booing drum booing Biden and
heckling him so it has become this very
odd fixture in the kind of American
political media calendar
um but I think a lot of Americans think
it's a bit odd and in fact viewing
figures I think they peaked with Obama I
think they've been steadily on the
decline I don't have the latest ones for
Biden but I'm gonna bet that they were
quite low is it just a matter of time
before there's product placement yeah I
think I think Trump even did a bit of
that oh really
let's say that he did Freddie thanks so
much for joining inspectus TV
that's it for this week once again
thanks to Canada wealth management for
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes can
Accord will provide you with the
expertise you need to help you build
your wealth with confidence visit
candywealth.com for more information
and if you enjoy spectator TV subscribe
to our YouTube channel click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss any of our videos
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week